I've never been so close for more than
50 years Japan has been at the forefront
of big physics creating experiments of
such size and the mission that they need
to be seen to be believed
my name is Davide Castel Becky and I am
one of nature's physics reporters in
this series I will be traveling to Japan
to visit three of its flagship
experiments delving inside Japan's big
physics about 50 kilometers northeast of
Tokyo is a city of Tsukuba home to
Japan's largest particle physics lab kek
when you arrive at kek you given a
radiation dosimeter to where the
experiments all around the facility are
smashing particles together which
releases some radiation although they
are highly controlled and very safe it
is always good to take precautions I am
here to see an experiment called Bell -
my name is Michiko
Nakao half of my time I'm working on the
data acquisition system of the Bell and
Bell - detectors and half of my time I'm
working on the physics analysis Bell -
is the second in a series of experiments
built to study an often overlooked
branch of particle physics be physics
the B in B physics refers to one of the
constituent parts of a particle called a
be messin B stands for bottom or beauty
and these particles have some
interesting properties B mesons aren't
stable particles which are very rare in
nature but they can be made in particle
accelerators and that is what bail to
does electrons and their antimatter
counterpart positrons collide at the
center of bail to and annihilate each
other producing two B mesons these
unstable methods immediately decay into
lighter particles and fly away by
measuring these decays and the
trajectories of the particles
researchers can look for places where
the numbers don't add up and that may be
the key to explaining some of the big
mysteries in the universe in particle
physics we have accumulated a lot of
data and we have established the so
called standard model of particle
physics but this is still lacking a lot
of things to answer the mystery of the
universe physicists like mikky ekko
believe that there could be some new
physics to discover which can explain
some of these mysteries one example is
that no antimatter is observed in our
universe and we don't know how this time
aromara involves was generated at the
very beginning something tipped the
balance some difference in behavior
between particles and antiparticles this
difference is called CP violation and it
is one of the things Bell too is
studying using B mesons back in 2001
Bell the predecessor to Bell - was among
the facilities that first measured the
CP violation in the decay of a penis an
Bell - is looking to confirm if those
were hints of new physics or just
statistical flutes
mikky ekko took me on a tour of the
detector to get a look at the
engineering that makes this all possible
so now we are coming to the Gurley area
of the vocal experimental hall and
usually we cannot go around the detector
area but because we are now in a short
on time we are allowed to go there
the hole containing bell 2 is vast and
around the Galleria flax from every
country that has collaborated on the
experiment over the years from Saudi
Arabia to Vietnam when I visited the
detector was still not fully operational
it had run some short tests but had been
shut down again so now we are top of the
beam line you can actually see the two
beam parts huge metal yokes had been
pulled apart and the detector had been
almost totally deconstructed which gave
us a rare chance to look inside off to
one side in a clean space researchers
were testing the most advanced part of
Bell to the silicon vertex detector
which can measure the origin of the
particle at the resolution of this 100
micro this will go into the center of
the detector and it is by measuring
these particles with incredible levels
of detail that mikky ekko hopes to
discover new physics
[Music]
as you approach the interaction point
you could see vast looms of wiring
containing all the detection mechanisms
which had been revealed we were able to
get closer than I ever imagined we would
in fact it was a new experience for me
Kiko - I said I'm not working in this
area usually so this is first time to
need to be here we are in front of our
Bell toll detector and what we are
seeing is the LED end cap part is opened
and in the cup detectors up taken out so
that we can see the internal detectors
and inside there like 14,000 wires it's
very often that people make the missed
connection then the swab the cable in
some places if you are lucky we can swap
the cable on the other side - and
everything is fine
so we're standing right in front of the
heart of the bell - detector there will
be the silicon vertex detector installed
in the very middle and then these two
final focused magnets will be inserted
from the two sides and that's where the
electrons and positrons will come and
meet at the interaction but before
collisions can occur first the
researchers at kek need to generate and
accelerate the particles that come out
of this cube and to do that you need
another vast piece of equipment
what particle physicists call the
machine this is the accelerator super ke
kab Michi Renisha walkie took me on a
tour of the tunnel that houses the beam
lines we are here we are here then a
bear yeah this is a super ke ke V
accelerator then electrons come from
there to there and put it on is coming
from there to there so it went on there
we have two rings like this each ring
carries either electrons or positrons
matter or antimatter they are
accelerated to close to the speed of
light using powerful radio frequency
waves and steered with a series of
magnets placed all along the beam line
the list of equipment involved in
creating accelerating shaping and
maintaining the beam is mind-boggling I
indexed on being foreigner from being so
that's gravity
dipole this is a accelerating cavity for
the ball the six purple tube in the pipe
this one is inject or injected being in
Textron game this is a rotating pin
waveguide that's five that is also
waveguide staring magnet
this is press wrong and this is a
cooling tower we have for Christ alone
and gets buried in and then we reach
this point the positron injection line
this is literally an antimatter injector
so you can see the injection line it's a
green magnets so so put it around come
from there then there me chiru's job is
to get consistent bunches of electrons
and positrons traveling in opposite
directions when the bunches reach
optimum conditions they are diverted
through - bail - and they smash together
super kek B does this much more
efficiently than its predecessor
so that bail - will collect B mesons at
a rate forty times higher than bail did
Mickey he con his team will have a lot
of data on their hands in recent years
major experiments in particle physics
have not found any direct evidence of
new particles so many researchers now CB
physics experiments as the most
promising place to look for new physics
and bail - could play a major role in
this new era for decades Japan has been
a world leader in big physics Japanese
detectors join other facilities around
the world and their vital contributions
to these complex and ambitious projects
is undeniable but when you are here it
is the scale of the experiments that
really stands out a scale which is
perhaps only rivaled by the scale of the
questions they are trying to answer
[Music]
[Music]